hi we're back Yeah right before holidays
yeah I fly out to the East Coast
tomorrow morning this is Wednesday the
20th i finished game of the air stuff
fly out Sunday yeah you guys announced
Zelda mm-hmm Zelda and then persona 5
and then three was Mario a safe choice
this game that we're about to be playing
is our number 4 name of the year
hi enough I'm kidding it's probably high
I haven't beaten it so I'm not really
allowed to say that it could be game of
the year but I will tell you this it's
on my top 10 on giantbomb even though I
haven't played it all the way through
and I believe in it sincerely even
though I haven't played it all the way
through I just know that it's gonna be
really good because they really [ __ ] up
the second half hold on give me two
seconds that light blotting the wall
behind you is annoying me okay sure
nobody cares as much but oh you mean
that blown out light right there your
attention to detail is second to none
Mike it's still blown out I mean are you
about me or you
it's your side the pink one yep much
better give you a little
behind-the-scenes action of what it's
like okay sweet sorry yeah no a screen
was long enough that you're lucky that
the loading screen is so long oh that
was you can fix a light in the
background and alright alright stop
messing with the mic my audio is a mic
it's the headphones my audio is all
weird now okay so I'm drinking already
this should be a good episode because I
did a lot of the early stuff that I was
supposed to do before I go into the
brothers Lucas don't worry it's not
affecting their step I know the brothers
place and I think he's like a crazy guy
with lots of animatronics and stuff so I
have animatronics I think so Oh like cuz
he made
yeah dummy it was like a jack-in-a-box
kind of clown guy and he did stuff so I
feel like that's gonna be involved
somehow I'm sure there's gonna be a boss
fight at some point so I'd like to
prepare for such a thing and I'd like
your advice on what to do so I have a
blue key card which I obviously need but
I can get rid of it immediately so
that'll save a slot I have no health
which is definitely not advised so let
me see did you have any more health yeah
I have herbs and oh [ __ ] I actually
already had herbs I have a lot of herbs
the problem is is I don't have enough
chem fluid but I have some chem blooood
oh god do I have any yellow oh shoot oh
no okay so I actually have no chem fluid
I only have strong chem fluid which
you've always said is like pretty
important I have one all right so let me
again let me first the structure of the
game so far has been like two hours and
then that boss and then two hours and
that boss the only hint they'll give you
it's just kind of so I did one hour well
no not necessarily one hour but like
because I do it up to the next like
chapter of the game okay you're saying
it could be another two hours before
boss
I would not plan for a boss fight okay
all right that's good to know
but I still expect him to be a [ __ ]
so as people have mentioned the burner
is not as usual post Marguerite just
because it doesn't stagger alright I'll
get rid of the burner I have a shotgun
with nine shells wait no yeah that seems
good okay go on I have a lot of
gunpowder but I don't have anything to
mix it with oh also people in the
comments were super helpful and reminded
me of something I forgot the hatchet
that I was wondering why you can't drop
it is used for a shadow puzzle in the
backyard now yeah go do it are you in
the trailer yeah let's do it I forget
what it gives you but you can go do it
let's go in here oh so then also you can
go back up and get the I have this
lockpick as well which seems valuable
you leave something else in the attic oh
I'm actually hurt I'm okay I thought we
left something in the air
well yeah the toy shock or now the I
don't know so over in that corner
somewhere I think I said
Oh
because they sometimes they put evil
stuff in the garden now so there's a
shadow puzzle somewhere yeah a pedestal
in the back stairs going up here oh no
that's in the blue pair that's in the
blue keycard thing I'm looking for what
sort of pedestal to put something on
like with light behind it like maybe on
the trip you know that would make sense
yeah it's so weird I did say it was over
here it they did sorry I'm actually let
me look it up but oh god you hear it oh
wait yeah you just kind of came into a
thicket oh right there nice sweet huh I
did it out of fear but it worked out god
those noises they're terrible oh so I
need to make a why I don't know it's the
number that a tax makes is that your one
three five seven four
what's that noise no one can attack you
lightens well tilt it back like do the
seven and then back toward us so that's
a seven yeah now like back towards us
like a thing the top toward us right
analog stick down yeah down or yeah
alright 8 a little more
there's evil seven I don't know there's
probably some clue is that fast reload
speed that's permanent right yeah so I
just eat this yeah
inject it Randhir god damn wrist oh
stressful okay cool thank you chat
that's super helpful okay so should I
save let's I thought we left something
in the Attic I knew there was something
in there I heard him lurking around the
Attic yeah member we didn't have a room
no we got that what was it the coin it
was in the fireplace is that we were
talking about no no I was a toy shotgun
what you go stright weights check your
inventory if it's not in there it's in
the attic and that will help you out
later okay
yeah yeah I didn't get that we should do
that okay for me for you okay let's do
that and then I want to save because I
get I have anxiety all right so it's all
the way upstairs right
God where is that thing I hate that it's
no longer safe out here
I do wish that this head like an outlast
like look behind you as you run thing
although that might defeat some of the
combat I just don't like this area I
have like a lot of bad memories here
because of Jack yeah ok so just in here
no that's the master bedroom it's the
I'm confused
it's the room it's Lucas's older room as
a child across next to the billiard room
kind of right got it and I expected
these things to turn alive and they
didn't at that point they didn't who
knows what's God's sakes okay so it's
the only way that I feel like I can
gather courage I don't like this area
either yeah
Oliver died up here that kid yeah and
they didn't show me his body isn't that
weird yeah oh yeah it's over there
yes all right sweet oh wait hold on I
want to point this out look at the
contractor named Trevor that ring a bell
Trevor you remember George Lisa and
Jessica Trevor George Trevor was the
architect who built Spencer mansion him
and Spencer
that's a nice little tidbit I mean it's
obviously not the same person right
because it's like are you saying it's
like in the family I was the same
construction phase Oh technically you
all his family dies so it must be he
doesn't pass on like you kill Lisa when
she turns Jessica dies before the events
of the first one now you have so much
more knowledge about this world than I
do is it him
I just thought bottom line is there it's
somehow connected to like umbrella and
all that [ __ ] so this is present-day
that was okay so I have the shotgun now
what do I do with it go go down to where
you put the broken shock and I got the
real shotgun yes and then get the broken
shotgun yeah next time you find a repair
kit you'll have a better shot gun
interesting so this this broken shotgun
is better than the shotgun I have is
that what you're telling what you have
right now is just a fake toy one this
one no no I mean the one that actually
the one that works I have a real working
shotgun correct and you're telling me
that the broken one once you repair it
it'll be better than the one you're
using got it okay that's what I wanted
to know okay so now I have two shotguns
but one of them doesn't work yeah we
just put in that trailer you got it and
then we go to the birthday party
I hope not birthday party the party oh
please don't I'm really looking forward
to this part is there a little Crawley
dude just leave me alone okay cool so
let's just prep for this birthday party
or whatever you're saying so should I
take this lockpick should I take I don't
need this broken shotgun so I'll put
that away I have five herbs which is the
max so actually I'm gonna put those away
because I expect to find an herb do you
know I mean yeah and I'm gonna take
I'm not texting I'm checking the time I
just realize that I not know what time
we start it's fine
we can go pretty long I mean to me I'm
good for like basically the day and I
also want to turn and do a couple
episodes because I'm not gonna be here
next week that way
anyone who's around for Christmas
basically like the week of Christmas
will have a backlogged episode ready to
go for you guys which i think is
important to me this will go up two days
before Christmas and then the next one
will go up like a week after so let me
ask you this do I need this strong chem
fluid do I I would take it okay I have
four herbs
nine shotgun shells nine bullets that's
not a lot and a lockpick should I take
the lockpick you should take the
lockpick oh and I have gunpowder should
I take six gunpowder
I'd take like so others I think I can
split this right am I allowed to do that
how do I do that you can't split the
gunpowder because that's a foundational
ingredient you could split like really
yeah you could split like
psychostimulants into supplements and
chem fluid well no I guess I might have
a pile of six and I don't want a pile of
thank you you're saying I think press
square and then now there was some way
to do it I don't want to use down once
press combine examine and discard like I
just kind of want to split if they're
stacking I don't think it matters well
didn't you say that after a while it
doesn't stack or doesn't sure what the
number is but I doubt you're gonna find
like ten all right
okay so so people mention that save
strong chem fluid for bullets grenades
launched around you could bring the
grenade launcher you have to be yeah you
should bring grenade launcher I should
bring the grenade launcher this is a
pretty big deal that you're telling me
to do that so I take another one it
takes up to one extra space I see you're
saying sorry but you still have a bunch
of space you're fine okay and then go
into your inventory after and go to
combine combine what if sr1 yep go down
to grenades
okay so solid fuel okay cool so I would
not make burner fuel anymore yeah just
focus on so where is the grenades right
back down right there supplements and
strong chem fluid makes zero rounds so I
have supplements should I bring some or
should I yes yes if you have burner if
you have those pucks bring some of those
I don't think you do right now but
you'll find them I thought I did are you
doing ring solid fuel that'll make a
flame burn aids but I okay so you want
me to do that you me to bring this move
one I figured it out there you go
and then I bet you I could cool I've got
it alright we did it and now go in your
inventory and make flame round I have
supplements yes you know to bring that
and then bring the other strong chem
fluid trust me I got this bring em bring
the other strong Kemp Lloyd yeah now go
back out join your inventory craft Oh
whatever we'll roll with it we're fine
you just freed up an inventory space
you'll be fine
you healed up you need a deal I did not
okay
inventory okay combine the supplements
and a strong can flow it for neuro
rounds I'm so stupid
uh I hit our one before I was in the
thing just make one of each grenade type
and then you'll be pretty good our
weapon terms and then one of those yeah
and then you could reload your grenade
launcher if you want free up space
anymore space dude I am so disappointed
with myself
you have full aim rounds in there now
cool we're set to go let's party
alright let me save now that I'm
absolutely [ __ ] that up I can't
believe that also by the way I've no
heal now except for herbs roll it will
be fine I can't believe I did that
I enjoyed it at least I was on yellow
like if nothing else I can be like cool
I have pure health raise your confidence
going into the party I don't know what
that means
yeah the party plan I have perfect
health
how dare you shot that first one's
really good well no the first one was
the second one I meant the first one
that landed the first one was a decoy
people in the comments are very
impressed at your ability to do the duck
dodge when you crouch yeah that's
totally on purpose calculators or
anything in that toilet welcome to
that's how they that a good Billy Joel I
feel like I don't they were from right
nearby here Oakland right I yeah they're
an Oakland band I didn't know that I
used to listen to them all the time in
high school though what does that say
Duke he was like well my favorite albums
yeah growing up but it's been a while
et what does let's Oh do you think other
parentheses yeah look at the ceiling I
was like this is a bit you know you're
drinking coffee I'm the one having beer
okay let's play
what's la Y all right
what what does et in la have to do with
anything
the plot thickens
okay yes I'm supposed to watch this
trip-hop should we turn this up handsome
dude you can't get a camera
oh that's the arms
stupid [ __ ] stand I don't want to go
back to how things were before my father
turn back the clock so we don't finger
down you can crawl around underneath
that filthy rotten house oh you looking
for them ingredients but you ain't gonna
find a goddamn thing
Ethan you make that serum Oh baby
here come on again what do you say why
totally messed up walk
he didn't say that this message would
self-destruct it just self-destructed
remember there was that treasure photo
do you know what it looked like I'll
just yeah I had like a baby's head on a
counter it was a mannequin head on top
of two cages like that
yeah I don't believe it's this one but
it might be coming up did you hear who
he was talking to off screen Evelyn Oh
remember that name has been mentioned a
few times and notes and stuff yeah the
photo of the little girl where is that
Evelyn but I haven't met them yeah
that's just like we've you've seen the
name around and I gotta go in they
reference her as like the reason things
happened okay so he said like before my
father Jack found you it was so she's
not family based on what we know yeah
it's just like they found Jack found her
he said y'all so like found a bunch of
people and things went wrong or right
according to Lucas
sorry I'm just like mentally prepping
myself my hands are really sweaty palms
spaghetti nice way comes a heavy mashup
that's really good encouraging me it
keeps on spaghetti can I break that do
not marry do not hit that with a grenade
launcher don't did you pick those up I
think so yeah you know that looks like a
tripwire that I don't want to trip are
we on the same page here sure
you're gonna see me take way longer now
because that one was obvious on purpose
and now there's gonna be sneaky ones so
there's one and it goes higher that's
weird
I'll just sneak under the high part
what's that noise
haha okay but that's regular handgun
ammo should I switch to that you think
or are mice fancy oh yeah okay l2o l2
and triangle yeah that's just something
I'm not gonna be able to do very well
when I need to do it yeah okay so
success Oh God okay there's another one
right there
oh [ __ ] it's really close okay
this corner looks safe
I wonder what happens when you trip it
you die or do you think it like sends
out like an evil guy or like like how
big is my punishment here it sends out
an evil guy that's some tripwire I mean
I guess yeah like one one molded it'll
probably just blow up
tripwire you just die yeah yes sir yeah
no don't look at the corner there to the
right oh there's the baby on the head
cage thing okay got it
baby on the head you very fixated on it
being a baby I think it's just a
mannequin head let's find out okay
tripwire
look there what's that I didn't see a
wire but I don't trust anything like
that's a tripwire oh you bastard oh my
god there's another one okay so they're
being really sneaky hello a repair kit
yeah I don't know what that is oh that's
for my gun yeah so ostensibly you could
have brought be broken shotgun yeah
there's a plenty of game after lucas's
sections okay
well oh Lord I actually don't know how
to do this like first person it's hard
to know how big your hitbox is like can
I squeeze in between that left wire
here's something worth considering the
explosions not big enough like if you
shot that right from here you could
shoot the explosives to negate the
tripwire you huh you'll use a bullet
which it's up to you whether you want to
use the bullet to make it easier to
here's my other question will I run back
through here dad I won't tell you dammit
alright I'm just saying for the purposes
of getting through this room I would
just chuck it either one would work I
would probably shoot the one under the
table go around that yeah maybe you
weren't supposed to be able to get that
by that one maybe you were but I mean
better safe than sorry
what I thought you were walking toward
that other one again I mean I am
observing it because that one was really
sneaky yeah if it wasn't for that super
bright red light because the wire you
don't see but you see the red lights
which is why I'm being very active in
looking for them I think that's it
there's one over there I think we're
good I don't see any but so what part of
the house is this is it still part of
the house I never really that's a good
question I guess it is yeah but like
okay I think I don't think there's
anything of value here I think it's just
a shitty area okay I'm gonna go through
Oh God there's molded-in here no ok I
don't know what that is is it tar yeah
Oh God
ma'am
I'm gonna get you out of here so I'm
getting a lot of handgun ammo which I
feel like is not great just helping you
blow [ __ ] up probably
Oh God
you [ __ ] bastard ah again a sense of
what the sections becoming about it's
like a trap or something yeah he's just
[ __ ] with me oh he's talking with you
cuz like I'm not gonna get the arm it's
not like he's gonna like dangle it on a
string like that other thing I feel like
oh [ __ ] okay there's two here so I could
definitely can't get through here unless
I blow one of them up and I know you can
see this area is weird what's that you
might have that might be like a stairs
there lowers you might have to see I'm
gonna crawl under eyes unless it's on
the ground I got it
I was the save box is this a safe room
oh I should be careful you could repair
that shotgun right now if you want yeah
you should definitely sure to get the
repair kit out okay I mean yeah I'm
found out okay so tell me this because
remember how we have that problem we're
like I had shotgun shells in both
shotguns and it's like yeah that'll
happen again I guess damn I hate that I
do that all right so I want to combine
with this repair kit yeah okay and it
came with two shotgun shells that's nice
so it's like a double-barrel shotgun
okay does that mean it shoots out two at
the same time
[Music]
no I believe it shoots one then two okay
so let me ask you this from now on
I should only be putting bullets in this
one right I mean because I have seven
shotgun shells so I really would just
put this it away for like a rainy day
cuz I'll accidentally I think we both
know what will happen
I don't yeah I guess so because I I
don't know if it's inherently better I
think the net damage is better with the
double-barrel you're talking about okay
I just put it away and I can always come
back for it so I want this to be no I
would honestly finish up the four shells
from the first one but just don't reload
like I feel like you don't I'll remind
you because like it later on has no
we're going to a boss fight with two
shotguns you're taking up a ton of space
like you want to use up the normal one
right now I feel like you don't I know
you know me it's far in cuz it says sees
how it says eleven like I'm gonna I know
what if I like hide these yeah put those
away put those in the put those and the
new shotgun away there you go and that
kind of forces me to not yea [ __ ] up
yeah but you still have four shotgun
shells you can use I don't like that
that is in my inventory the grenade
launcher because I'm really afraid even
accidentally is it well don't tell me
what to do you can't tell me what to do
do you see any other explosives okay and
then this is a number but I don't know
what the number he wants us it's
probably written somewhere inspect the
room I'll save that okay
there are these pipes and there's some
crates and a save box that was nice and
then there's this wall
sealing sticking the time here taking my
time
there's some weird pointy nails there I
look at that more closely the nails it's
that whole area you got it
makes a shadow on the wall me too much
okay well I thought I saw an X I didn't
I was thinking it would just be like
should I shoot these pipes if any cuz it
looks like there if anything shoots a
rope holding them right okay yeah sorry
right back up yeah that makes sense like
it looks like yeah she the ropes but
don't walk into the path of the pipes I
don't know if this will work I'd okay
well just do the you know you know the
danger you're in at least yeah so those
those swing into me if I get it wrong
yeah but you'll have it you'll have a
second to dodge it let's just go to the
number pad thing try to open the door no
[ __ ] password right why don't you try
a zero eight one four zero six should be
writing this down
no it's zero five one four come on take
a chance you never know
zero six eight four was the first thing
you said I think no I think it was the
first one he said whatever that was zero
six one four zero five one four is the
first one that he says try that then how
do i dodge
[Music]
I was incorrect [ __ ] I don't know I
doesn't matter can you open the door now
oh god damn it he said too many numbers
zero six look in the room in there
remember recognize the room though yes
it's the same one from that guy
he said zero six to one as well was
Diddy are you sure I don't remember
either oops I need to find the password
now yeah I know that oh maybe it's up
here cuz that changed you know what I
mean like the nails are over there now
that's the only thing that's changed in
this room which makes me feel like you
don't remember this part do you know oh
you'd look through the door and it's
somewhere in the room I don't like that
noise stop pushing on the door well look
in the room like aim okay
we're just go back I guess I'm missing
something I just don't know all right
let's go back what was that what was
that
oh where did this come from
I'm so confused when with you he open it
he wants you go this way
is that a tripwire he's doing a really
good job of like giving me anxiety okay
oh you bastard
should I just shoot Oh gross yeah so
should I shoot the boxes yeah if you use
regular handgun bullets the net ammo
gain I think in the end is worth it okay
no you use a bullet it's time yeah cuz I
don't remember which specific ones have
rigs on them okay I'm just gonna look
this area over for trip wires before I
do this okay
I think we're good I'll do this one
first it's actually better that you did
the explosive one first you can waste
two bullets I could make a health kit
with that I don't have a health kit
right now because I had what's in the
cabinet all right that's okay I'm gonna
make it because I feel I feel like I
should have one also I'll probably
accidentally use it or some [ __ ] so
damn it's a bummer not needing to do it
burner fuel that's like one of the worst
ones to get are they Rando or they
planned I don't know I think they're
planned so one thing I don't like about
divinity is the random drops because
every once in a while I'll like find a
secret in the game that like a designer
clearly went out of his way to be like
if they're smart they'll go up here and
find this secret little island and I'll
find this island it'll have a treasure
chest in it and it will have nothing
there random so sometimes you go through
this extravagant deal and nothing cool
comes of it I feel like I should stand
but I don't want to go ahead and stand
go a shot I [ __ ] heard him before
that sucks
I'm disappointed I thought he was in
here because when I stood up I heard him
I wonder where he came from
now I'm super paranoid oh [ __ ]
I was close should I shoot it oh okay
have a door and I have a gnome no that's
not a gnome that is a cone on a bench a
gnome I thought it was a little gnome
like a garden gnome a cone on a bench I
don't you think that's what it is
[ __ ] you okay there's two tripwires in
here oh god there's three okay so I have
to get rid of I have to get rid of at
least that one okay there's still two in
here good eye
skadoosh this guy that's good I'm gonna
laugh if that explodes I don't think it
will
god damn this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
your unread or to still yellow it's
yellow that guy sucks anything else
there better be where I just want to
know where I'm allowed to go here cuz I
don't want to get killed there's nothing
in here worth dying for
I think I can get to there safely
yeah oh that's not worth it that is it's
not I'm just get a Magnum those things
are the best thing in the game I know
but priorities son this guy sucks
alright do you think there's something
over here hey check you're good to walk
over there I did not think you were good
to stand up but apparently why okay like
I'm not great but I'm okay mmm-hmm
alright I don't see anything
Thank You sis
all right I'm on yellow this area is
clean that area still has a tripwire it
makes me want to shoot them because I'm
afraid I might have to run back through
here but I don't know that yet and I
don't want to waste the ammo if that's
not the case
do you see any trip wires you have to
tell me if you do know this area takes
ten times as long when you think you
could be walking into it
I hear it where are you I hear him you
hear him I hear him where is it okay
back up into the hallway don't shoot
don't shoot him back I'm in the hallway
crouched under the wire and lead him
into the wall right come get my jack
that's awesome that's so cool you could
go if you can get around me go into the
other room you have one bullet shotgun
shells
yeah go back into that shed room and
then like trick him again as long as
you're not too close the explosive oh
what's that oh he's not gonna trip these
but is there one left I got one bullet
baby I hit that one thing all right
rolled it damn it I was not very good
really good I would go back quickly to
the item box and recover some things
like shotgun get the other shotgun [ __ ]
I'm actually why am i running let's do
this very you already went through this
I would run oh oh no there's not
not until now you got rid of already
tripping yeah you shot this one in case
I tripped over all of them yes what what
I used a health kit and I'm on yellow
yeah I must have been that close to
death yeah all right get rid of that
shotgun get the other one okay so
goodbye I can't believe I accidentally
tripped over that thing okay so the m21
mm-hmm the shells and the shells and
then we're good
mm-hmm I have some Maggie
I might have some I mean so I have the
ability to make bullets because I got a
chemistry no no I use it separate the
burner fuel if you don't need that into
a chem fluid sure I think so get the
separating agent yeah try that this
right no click on the separating agent
yeah yeah and then combine and then
combine with the burner fuel okay
combined with this I can't why not oh
yeah you can yeah do that
you think this is worth it right yeah
yeah you can't it's not highlight why
not I don't know you can do it on the
grenades but don't do that
no I'm not going to maybe oh you need
100 burner fuel it's only 30 oh I have
one I think hold on sorry I actually do
think I do
oh it might just be in puck form I do
you know I can look though I have 30 can
I combine that no that's only 80 bring
it now keep the put the other burner
fuel in the inventory right now and then
bring the five herbs I have four oh
never mind then let's go up an antique
coin oh and I have this supplements do I
need that yeah I keep them in case you
need grenades let's go
okay go I wish I could save theirs
auto-saving - yeah you're right into the
barn again I have no [ __ ] ammo I will
stick with my gun for now those things
were beastly I'm so bummed that tripped
that wire at the end really I'm not
damn it I was doing really well until I
almost killed myself okay so hopefully
there's no more hopefully
there was like five like yeah two of
them were crawlin but like and they were
all like in here okay sorry I'm like
super paranoid I will say I know it's
like trapped Laden but I you are you
could speed up a little bit I think like
in the interest of time finishing it
there's gunpowder ah yes yeah can't
[ __ ] make anything with it because
they never give me enough chem fluid I'm
so rich in gunpowder it's ridiculous
I have one fella who wants it this area
sucks super freaky okay I'm going in
here oh it's a safe room great it's got
a little TV wait yeah I could have just
done that here yeah that's all right
okay so I'm gonna get rid of these pucks
yeah and we already did everything we
wanted so I'm gonna save real fast and
let's keep gone can you open that tackle
box oh I no longer can make new save
files cuz I've made like thousands
should I start from the bottom then go
down yeah literal bottom because this is
the most recent I just got to be really
careful there you go never breathe yeah
okay okay
oh you okay alright so I might have a
tape coming up I can't believe oh
there's a tripwire there
let's check this area out should I shoot
it not with an enhanced handgun round is
that enhanced or no I don't know I don't
I think so
it's either that or I [ __ ] stab it
and hope it doesn't kill me sure can't
blew it which I make health with it yeah
probably considering that's what
normally happens to me yeah I'm so dumb
I'm so disappointed with myself
sorry I have a bit of anxiety here that
one I'm less trusting of well I could
shoot it but hold on okay I hold out to
you and the press triangle I cannot wait
so I go up to the handgun yes I guess
just shoot it yeah you have shot enough
shotgun shells to handle yourself for a
while yes you did
pocket oh it was exploding no I don't
think it was oh yeah whatever you got
strong Keppler whatever
should I make strong bullets because I
have no bullets to this gun right no
just go with your shotgun for now you
might run into like a mini boss when you
grenades for okay
you're finding a decent amount of
shotgun shells throughout the game um I
don't know what to do here looks like I
have to fall in is that thick oh well I
fell in a little earlier than I wanted
okay this looks like a [ __ ] area cuz
like I'd like hate using stuff you
probably just knife this box actually I
don't know search around for maybe we'll
get hanging a table first
okay so there's that then there's that
everything's in mean box form I can come
back up there's a battery
okay there's boxes everywhere start
knifing really yeah I guess are you
saying down there I can always eat a an
herb god damn it I could like resave or
something this is man oh [ __ ] that one
there's no way that one's gonna explode
- right I don't know that's so cruel
well let's go open some goddamn boxes I
hope they have chem fluid and there's
speakers in here god damn it yeah
there's one in the corner here yeah
right I hit the only one that I could
hit more shotgun shells are you good
alright ok so I need to put the battery
in here ye and then I think some shits
gonna go down [ __ ] sake I forgot about
that I promise I did not know
[Music]
where are they gonna come from know
where things are going - what is that
[ __ ] him up - yeah yeah yeah Gary look
[Music]
oh hey Joe good you having out hey cuz
I'm using this corner Rainbow six C's oh
oh he goes really slowly really glad you
repaired the shotgun now but it's
staggering it son oh I thought good dog
[Music]
hi-yah I'm running out of bullets so if
you had used the regular shotgun for
that you probably use another five shell
is there another one I'm like don't have
enough bullets for this what I was
drilling I thought you were pointing no
humming nice job there you go
is that it yeah that's gnomes that
doesn't seem right
yeah and like that shotgun helps that
was really good
okay [ __ ] how am i doing in health all
right I'm still in yellow I really I
could have eaten herb sure oh you are
right went to eat the five at stop
stacking I told you well for herbs at
least not ammo not specific maybe I was
gonna eat this okay okay did I do it I
don't even know if it helped we got you
to higher yellow I'm sure how do you
know that just they heal you grab that
boot on I have a lot of herbs I have
another pack of five throw that you're
probably getting autosave soon no well
I'm glad I got everything torches ignite
and kill you I did you growing up I'd
rather go up and down in this game
that's true where am I going
alright it's gonna open no what's that
that's to get me to go back right
I don't know if you can let me know if
you see any tripwires okay sorry I'm
like super paranoid it's understandable
where's that okay it's coming from that
I think we're okay I think this is just
an ordinary hallway oh god okay so I'm
in the house Nora nari hallway with a
burn victim in it there's that second
stems okay
sorry I'm like and I'm good yes okay
good I think I don't have any health
should I get some health I'd hold off
for now until you might need it okay
he's got something nailed this was Mia
he reads in here you see that okay I
want to reiterate this if this house was
not so [ __ ] up it would be awesome
you're next oh there's a password soon
damn it
one four zero eight in 1408 Columbus
tougher Columbus sailed the ocean great
is that the guy that I saw in the video
oh [ __ ] is that Clancy Jarvis yeah he
got burned it seems possible right I
don't know that I considered that before
was it one four zero eight okay just I
don't want to come back children's nurse
around in 1408 Columbus sailed the ocean
great yes he was such a great sailor
they always said I'm kind of a [ __ ]
really a big [ __ ] okay so [ __ ] him
all right okay now we're back but the
stairs no it was a hardware can I go in
here as is no okay why would you want to
get to it I thought maybe there was like
a secret this game has programmed me
that their secrets and traps and secret
but mostly traps fired oh it's so cool
that was Ethan or Clancy Oh
unless he's done that to numerous other
people I'm gonna put the coin away and
then do I need both of these like I
bring one move one okay
anything else
I'm like running out of good I have like
nope I'm like anxiety riddled I have no
bullets I have a decent amount of those
grenades yeah look at the room you're
going into like you know what to expect
it's like a puzzle room yeah and for ten
hundred and eight Columbus sailed the
ocean grace I should teach kindergarten
yeah what do you mean get rid of
everything yo I have to get rid of
everything anything sell you anything
you can use I say so this is like a
brain teaser or not uh yeah member you
did this escape room as Clancy and got
burned alive yeah you think you wouldn't
notice the knife yeah I thought I could
conceal it he's watching you look at the
balloon popped right there oh wow why
the lights go off I don't know guys kind
of reminds me of Christmas I'm only on
yellow like a kid does that mean
well they wouldn't make me just do the
same puzzle again cuz that'd be really
boring so they must do something
different this time
so consider the fact that you know you
kind of have to maybe not assume but
like consider the fact that Lucas does
not know that you saw that tape so right
no they so he doesn't know but I know
what he's gonna do
and she use that to your advantage he's
gonna light the room on fire anyway
that's what he does that's a kiss stick
so and so what was so instead of that's
air
do you remember what initially started
and then that's where the fire goes out
through the water when I get the valve
do you ever pass word to the door um so
it was when you pull the plug out of the
barrel then the oil started pouring out
and that's what burned you alive so you
don't want to do that and that's
essentially the first thing you need it
to do so you need to like bypass some
stuff so you can burn that rope to your
left right thank you are maybe
all right not to anything your ex I mean
the [ __ ] maybe I have to go in the water
once ya mean do you know what I mean
like maybe sure that turns the lights on
so I will not pull that out kiss my ass
[Music]
okay so I think I do remember yeah hold
on let's just do this for funsies okay
no hints
there was no apple there was a fetus
there was a bird on a tomb and there was
a hanging guy I just don't know if I
remember the order I think it's baby and
then bird I said or bird and the baby I
said no I'm just thinking about I
honestly don't know sweet I honestly
can't remember that yeah I guess you
could go from here but absolutely the
password would still be the same and
you're just kind of you don't need to do
this
cuz I need them come on it's a nice
little touch
yeah so I did all things go back to the
flame while you're here you might as
well burn the doll encase and what do I
do with it the quill that writes on your
arm or it's the dummy finger that holds
the quill right do I need that part no
like so no don't even because you can't
you can't activate the dummy without the
barrel plug that was the thing that goes
in this chest right and I don't want to
do that yeah and then you go into the
toilet for this telescope you don't you
already did that there you go so now you
can yeah yeah it was just because I
hadn't done that first part Oh
loser yeah lobby
like at what point does Ethan go or like
does that guy go you [ __ ] like
you cheated cuz I'm obviously cheating
cheating this is life and death cares I
mean I don't I'm just saying like I'm
cheating like he would probably be
pissed off if he knew that I was
cheating okay so now I do this I turn
that part off semantics wouldn't you
turn it right to tighten it to close it
off
righty-tighty probably whatever maybe
it's different in Japan okay okay
so now it okay so now we're good yeah
cuz normally you get the balloon with
the thing in it and then you would put
it over the air dang and it blow up now
let me ask you this it explodes right
yeah am I gonna get hurt yeah do it
anyway and should I start to consider
how I'll get out of here good idea so
there's that way which I think will be
locked I assume because this place is
gonna be on fire
well not as on fire if you did it right
there's no oil on it there's no oil but
it's still gonna be on fire but it'll be
I wouldn't assume it would be safe
alright so was this place was there any
other exit I go through here also maybe
if you solve it he'll just let you go
because he is weird like that like I
don't think so
[Music]
run yeah get away from the cage I'm
trying I don't think it actually hurt
you yeah so you're not a fire what I
need to leave ground there you go
pick that up what are you stop standing
there oh he was right there [ __ ] Lucas I
gets my goat you know what that kind of
reminded me of a little bit was portal
because yeah it was like all these very
carefully constructed things and I like
cheated and I think that's just a nice
feeling when you're able to do that
sound design quickly uh you know how
when you have a TV on in a room even if
there's no noise you'd be teletón
because it's got that really
high-pitched frequency noise well you
can hear that right now with that TV on
can you hear that is that just me what's
that Mia and Zoe yeah yeah Hara that's
so southern what the [ __ ] do you want
you dead guess that's not the cars not
yet lucky me
look unless you have any more surprises
up your sleeve I suggest you
and I don't do spoilers he'd be good to
at least see Star Wars with because we
wouldn't ruin it all right light showers
okay
I'm not like a uber Star Wars fan Carly
doesn't put me in the best light in a
lot of people's eyes I like Star Wars so
like I enjoy Star Wars so I just watch
it as a regular movie it was
entertaining we're not gonna spoil it I
will not I will not spoil it I won't say
anything but I'm just saying I thought
it was fine it's it's just another movie
for me it's entertaining and it's your
[ __ ] back now yeah I think it's probably
good time to call the episode that was a
little more than an hour I think yeah
yeah when we'll do another one right
sure well for people watching it's gonna
be another week sorry yes but we're
gonna do another episode for the
Christmas break so we won't be taking a
week off or anything yeah so if you're
watching this today on Saturday thanks
for joining us yeah two days if you're
celebrating Christmas hope you have a
good Christmas all right hopefully you
had a great Hanukkah Kwanzaa yeah
hopefully holidays in general hope
you're having good times you don't
hopefully have to [ __ ] your work hug
someone you like that's the least you
could do yeah cool well I'm gonna games
catch up on grab some stuff and I'll
save and we'll call that
do you even want you undo the stuff next
episode sure okay so if you guys like
this kind of stuff don't forget to Like
and subscribe to GameSpot that does help
them you know I'm saying that selflessly
because I can Merry Christmas or
generous GameSpot's from me I almost
didn't do the outro of animation May and
we'll just stop the recording that would
have been not as professional as you're
losing your touch